was sie erzählt klingt unglaublich
krankenschwester angelika pfleger ist
sich sicher dass ihr seit 1975
vermisster bruder ermordet und in der
garage ihres hauses des eigenen
elternhauses einbetoniert worden ist und
zwar von ihrem ex mann der eine baufirma
betreibt weil ihr der verdacht
schlaflose nächte bereitet und die neuen
hausbesitzer gegen eine ausschachtung
sind beginnt pfleger anfang mai nachts
heimlich zu buddeln
und sie möchte die pflaster abtragen und
nachschauen ob ihr bruder da wirklich
ein betoniertes mögliche beton leiche im
thüringischen gera angelika flieger
glaubt dass ihr bruder matthias 1995
ermordet und einbetoniert wurde unter
die garage ihres ehemaligen elternhauses
von ihrem ex mann der es betreiber einer
baufirma 1975 verschwindet ihr bruder
und angelika ist sich sicher die leiche
wurde einbetoniert doch das haus wurde
inzwischen verkauft und der neue
besitzer will eine ausschachtung nicht
zulassen
im mai bricht angelika flieger in die
garage ein und fängt nachts an zu
buddeln heimlich drei stunden lang mit
hammer und meißel trägt sie bei
quadratmeter beton pflastersteine ab
dann soll sie fündig geworden sein
als ich dann gegraben hatte nach einer
gewissen zeit ist schon aufgebaut mit
hammer und meißel bin ich dann auf also
ziemlich schnell auswahl an der
betondecke bin ich auf knochen gestoßen
knochenteile gestoßen
sie sind kleine stückchen gewesen die
ich immer nur abstimmen konnte im beton
sollen health note 5 knochenteile
gesteckt haben als krankenschwester ist
sie sich sicher sind teil eines fingers
gefunden zu haben die proben werden nun
im labor untersucht und die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt folgt
das verfahren am amtsgericht gera
allerdings gegen die totengräberin weg
hausfriedensbruch und jan schumann ist
vor gericht und steht dort und
beobachtet heute den tag vor gericht
also jetzt steht frau kläger vor gericht
warum denn
ja sie steht sie vor gericht erst mal
wegen hausfriedensbruch sie ist
sozusagen erstmal selbst angeklagt weil
sie sozusagen in einer nacht und
nebelaktion auf fremdes grundstück
ganges und nach ihrem toten bruder
gesucht hat und die beweggründe selbst
werden den richter wahrscheinlich heute
erstmal nicht interessieren
und nun sagt sie ja sie hätte da
tatsächlich knochen gefunden und hat
dort angeblich beweise für den tod und
für das einbuddeln ihres bruders
gefunden ist das denn richtig hat man da
information hast du der information von
der polizei wir haben die polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft jetzt mehrmals
gesprochen man will sich zum diesem
zeitpunkt des verfahrens noch nicht
wirklich äußern
es ist aber schon merkwürdig dass man
selbst die details also weder bestätigen
möchte noch dementieren
also es ist nichts sicher es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen aber auch nicht bestätigt
dass diese knochenfunde so zu sagen dass
es diese knochenfunde gegeben hat die
selbst sagt ja die kripo hält die spuren
gesichert
und diese werden jetzt sicher
ausgewertet dann erwartet man denn da
ein ergebnis auch das wie gesagt wird
die staatsanwaltschaft und auch die
polizei nicht beantworten weil wie
gesagt noch nicht mal beantworten möchte
ob es diese knochen von überhaupt
gegeben hat man dementiert sie aber auch
nicht